today on the matt wall show the right
celebrates a new poll showing a majority
approval for laws banning men from
women's sports but i think the truth
is not quite as rosy as it's being made
out to be the left is playing the long
game and they're winning as always also
five headlines including
an abortion ban in alabama a new
left-wing autonomous zone quote-unquote
in minneapolis and
the soap company dove has decided to
stop using the word normal in its
advertising because it might be
offensive apparently and our daily
cancellation will deal with a feminist
writer who's worried that stay-at-home
moms might be setting a bad example for
their children
all of that and more today on the matt
wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know we all know one of the most
important things that you can do for one
of the most important gifts you can give
yourself
is a good night's sleep so much of so
much of of your day hinges on how well
you rested
uh are you gonna have a good day a bad
day it all it all starts with whether or
not you got some sleep
and that means that one of the one of
the best gifts you could really give
yourself
is a my pillow product or especially a
my pillow pillow which is going to help
you get that good night's sleep
my pillow products don't go flat you can
wash and dry them as many times as you
want and they maintain their shape
best of all they're made right here in
the usa given american jobs which is so
important if you don't have a my pillow
or if you know someone who doesn't have
one yet
now's the time to get one because for a
limited time my pillow is offering their
premium
my pillows for their lowest price ever
you can get a queen size
premium my pillow which is normally
69.98 and get it for 29.98 that's 40
in savings the kings are only five
dollars more now is the time to buy if
you've been if you've been thinking
about this putting it off
uh don't put it off anymore get yourself
a my pillow go to mypillow.com click on
the radio listener square
there you'll find not only this amazing
offer but also deep discounts on all my
pillow products including
the giza dream bed sheets the my pillow
mattress topper and my pillow towel sets
or you can call 800-651-1148 use promo
code
daily wire as you know i tend to focus
more on the dark
cloud within the silver lining that's
sort of my thing and that's why
i can't join in some of the right wing
chest thumping and celebration i've
noticed
over a new poll in politico which finds
dear conservatives tell it
wide approval for banning males from
female sports
a majority of americans in fact do not
believe that
men who identify as women should be
allowed in women's sports a majority
what a victory clearly our arguments are
winning the day
at least that's how it's being presented
by some on the right
ever willing and eager to delude
themselves
let's look at the actual numbers this is
from a politico poll of course
take all of the necessary spoonfuls of
salt to go along with these poll results
because it is politico
but to the extent that we can actually
trust the results
here's what it says reading now from
politico it says former president donald
trump railed against transgender
athletes and female sports in his cpac
speech
a few weeks ago other prominent voices
on the right have joined in calling it
an example of political correctness
having a real world
impact our latest politico morning
consult poll
shows broad support for the gop position
extending across gender age and to a
lesser degree party
overall 53 of registered voters support
banning transgender athletes from
competing in women's sports
versus a third who oppose such a ban now
broken down into categories um here's
what it looks like
men 59 support a ban 29
oppose for women 46 support a ban
34 oppose then you go to republicans
republicans it's 74
support uh 15 opposed for democrats
40 supportive bands supposedly 42
percent opposed independence
49 supported band 33 percent opposed
generation z 43 supported band 44
opposed millennials 56 percent support
of ben 28 percent opposed
then baby boomers 50 support a ban
32 percent opposed now the one thing
that i'll i like about this poll is that
it further proves
that millennial awokeness didn't happen
out of nowhere
you know as critical as i've been of my
own generation and for good reason it's
not like we went insane on our own
the insane millennial generation was
raised by the insane boomer generation
that's the way these things go
uh apples falling not far from the tree
as
uh we know the saying goes in fact
according to this the boomers are even
more on board with left-wing gender
theory than millennials are
that also is no surprise as gender
theory was not invented in
2013 or whenever people think but 40 or
50 years before that
but the main point here is that yes a
majority hold
the only sane and reasonable position a
person can hold on this topic
that a male is still a male even if he
identifies otherwise
and therefore does not belong in female
sports
yet this is a position held by 53
percent of the country
that percentage should be 99
and if this question had been asked 20
years ago it would have been
99 now i can't prove that because
nobody was asking it 20 years ago
because it was it was an idea
so off the wall and crazy back then that
nobody bothered to ask it
what this means is that the left has
taken this idea
from one that was so crazy that nobody
even mentioned it
to one that nearly half of the country
believes and accepts
and they've done it in less than two
decades
see that's not a win for the right
that's not really encouraging
the long-term trends are thoroughly in
the favor of the left
so the right looks at this kind of poll
and says phew
looks like we win the left looks and
says
we will win we are winning
the right takes solace in the right now
at the very moment
you know that they've got a slim
majority on their side the left is
playing the long game
the left is thinking about the future
they know that five years from now
those numbers in that poll are going to
be reversed
15 years from now the majority position
today
will be seen as a fringe and radical
crazy minority
viewpoint 15 years from now they can
have this assurance not based on any one
poll because again take it with a great
assault
also you have to consider with a poll
like that uh how was it
how was it phrased if the question was
phrased
like should we ban transgender athletes
from women's sports well
i mean you could argue that well no we
shouldn't because if it's a if it's an
actual female who identifies as
transgender
they shouldn't be banned from women's
sports so it could have been
phrased in a way that's confusing but i
think most people understand what the
question means
but it's not just this one poll we
talked last week about the gallup survey
showing that trans identification among
gen z is 10 times higher than older
generations 10 times
this poll showing a majority of gen z
opposing a ban goes along with that
so the left knows that it has the future
because it has your children
it's fighting this fight generationally
and it's been fighting that way
for generations what this means is that
conservatives sure
should advocate laws and policies like
these bans i've been saying that for
years
it's a winning fight for conservatives
right now and so we should take
advantage of that
and act on that right now but that can't
be the be
all and end all we have to start
thinking long term
we have to start taking radical steps to
change
what now seems to be inevitable in the
future
now i've talked many times about what
some of those steps should be part of
the plan as you always hear me say
is to raise and educate your children in
an environment
free from left-wing indoctrination that
means no public school system
it also means dialing way back on their
exposure to pop culture and the internet
none of that is easy to do okay we are
talking about radical
lifestyle changes but if we aren't
willing to make
radical lifestyle changes then there's
no hope
the complacency and self-delusion on the
right can't continue this unfounded
faith
that things will simply work out that
the world can't get any crazier that the
left has finally crossed
the line this time and people are going
to wake up this is too far
all that needs to end the collapse of
our civilization
has been a highly deliberate act a
result
part of a long-term plan set in motion
by people who
say what else you want about them
certainly know how to play for keeps
and win none of this means that we're
doomed or we should give up quite the
opposite i'm saying the opposite of that
it simply means that we need to face
reality
understand how we got here where we're
going next
and start fighting for victories that
will last longer than
this present moment let's get to our
five headlines
[Music]
here's a controversial statement it kind
of sucks to have
acme i think we could all maybe that's
maybe it's not controversial maybe
that's one thing
wide agreement the polls will show 99
approval on that statement
uh nobody wants acting and the great
thing is if you have acne you don't have
to
uh you don't have to suffer through it
there is something you can do about it
you can be proactive by getting
proactive
proactive combines gentle skin care
paired with the best acne treatment for
your skin proactive has
three different systems designed for
your skin type and those three systems
they all do different things there's
proactive
md advance which is prescription
strength for stubborn breakouts they've
got proactive plus
gentle for more gentle skin types and
then the proactive solution original
which is the tried and true original
system suitable
for all skin types and that could always
be a go-to no matter what your skin type
is
a simple three-step system designed for
you all with clinically
proven ingredients and tested by
dermatologists this stuff works that's
what you need to know about it
right now it's a great time to try
proactive for our podcast listeners you
can get a special offer available
by going to proactive.com walls
productive subscribers will receive the
hydrating duo as a free gift
that includes four hydro gel masks and
the green tea moisturizer
you also get free shipping on top of
that again visit proactive.com
walsh to take advantage of this special
offer now that's proactive.com walsh
and subscribe to clearskin by the way i
wanted to tell you uh if you go to
my youtube page right now as we get
geared up for the debut of
candace owens new show which we're all
really excited about i did interview her
uh you can go to my my youtube page and
check out that we've got we've pulled
out a few
interesting clips from there but then
also we've got the full interview posted
with candace
um and i i did want to speak to one
thing though because
there's there's been controversy that's
come out of that interview already
and frankly lies have come out of that
defamation towards me because
many people who watch the interview have
accused me
of wearing skinny jeans in the interview
and i want to tell you right now that
i do not have not ever at any point in
my life
worn skinny jeans any claim to the con
to the contrary is spurious
and defamatory so if the genes appear to
be skinny
it was it's a it's a combination of
camera tricks
just kind of the way i was sitting
sitting the lighting all of those things
those were normal genes of all of the
things i've been accused of
in my time doing this all of the
accusations leveled at me
that is perhaps the worst
i'm simply not going to stand for it but
you can go check out that um
that interview where me and my normal
genes i am interviewing candy
candace owens okay number one from the
daily wire republican
arkansas governor asa hutchinson signed
senate bill six
on tuesday that bans abortion unless the
life of the mother is an injured so this
is
almost a full-on abortion ban supporters
of the bill hope that it could force the
supreme court to revisit
roe v wade though opponents intend to
block it before the law takes effects
effect later this year um republican
state senator jason rapper
the bill's sponsor said we must abolish
abortion in this nation just as we
abolish slavery in the 19th century
all lives matter hutchinson was at first
reluctant to sign the bill because it
didn't provide exceptions in the case of
rape or incest but explained in a
statement
that he ultimately decided to support it
now a couple of things here first of all
there absolutely should not be
exceptions for rape
rape and incest when it comes to
abortion bans
um there should be exceptions for the
life of the mother either
and the reason for that is very simple
that that's a non-existent category
so you might say it's no harm to put it
in there because that doesn't
that's not something that really exists
as in a life-saving abortion is not
something that exists
abortion has never saved the life of a
mother
there's never been a time when a woman
needed an abortion which is
an abortion what does that mean it means
to directly and intentionally kill
the child that's never been necessary to
save the life of of the mother now there
have been plenty of times
when um you know especially you know we
hear this especially with with late late
term abortions
where we're told by the left that uh the
only reason why a woman would get a
late-term abortion is
is you know a catastrophic medical
situation
where she needs it to save her own life
well yeah there may be cases
where the pregnancy has to end in order
to save the woman's life
the question is whether you kill the
child before you end the pregnancy
because one way or another especially
later term if you're ending the
pregnancy it means there's going to be a
delivery it means you are taking the
child
out of the mother's womb right and
absolutely if that needs to happen to
save the mother's life do it
the question is do you do you take the
extra step
of killing the child before you extract
him
from the womb or even as you are
extracting them from the wound which is
what they do in partial birth abortions
there's no way that you would need to do
that in order to save the mother's life
i mean there could be other cases really
difficult cases where a woman where
she's pregnant uh
you know is diagnosed with advanced
stage cancer and she's told that look if
you treat the cancer it might kill the
child
um but that's not an abortion either you
know taking a step
to treat an illness a disease or cancer
in a mother even if it were to have the
effect
tragically of killing a child that is
not to directly and intentionally kill a
child so that's not an abortion
so this is a made-up category the reason
i'm actually opposed to putting those
exceptions in
is that um the way that what the left
wants to do with the life of the mother
they want to expand that
to mean well not just life but physical
well-being
and by well-being we also mean emotional
well-being
and suddenly by the way that they
categorize it every abortion
in some sense preserves the life of the
mother
because of nothing else that preserves
her emotional well-being
um and for rape and incest you know the
reason why the exception shouldn't be in
there
to me again is is is simple which
doesn't make it easy
but it's simple just in the fact that uh
we do not punish children
especially with execution for crimes
committed by their
father that's that's not what
what you do in a civilized society you
want to talk about abortion execution
for rapists we can talk about that i'm
all ears
but you can't punish the child for that
that's why i think you don't make the
exceptions but uh in this case this is a
even with that that exception in there
this is something to be
celebrated and um will it will it cause
this confrontation
on the supreme court i don't know it
seems kind of far-fetched
it also seemed far-fetched that even if
it makes it to the to the supreme court
that this supreme court with its current
makeup
would vote to overturn roe v wade
gorsuch kavanaugh i
you know roberts i don't see any of them
voting to overturn roe v wade but even
so
um it's uh it is certainly a major step
in the right direction and alabama
should be uh should be praised and
celebrated for that
okay number two fox 40 reports
minneapolis leaders say they'll reopen a
barricaded intersection known as
george floyd square after the murder
trial of the former police officer
accused of killing him
but the activists who serve as
unofficial leaders and organizers of
this area have issued 24 demands
before they'll step aside even calling
for a recall of the county prosecutor
so they're making demands they they've
occupied this
part of the city and they're not going
to leave until they until we until their
demands are met
um here's a report done by uh reporter
brian enton
who is exploring this issue further and
encounters some of the
insurrectionists and terrorists
occupying this part of the city here's
how that went let's watch
this area behind me uh is the george
floyd memorial this is where george
floyd
was killed back in may take a look these
bay arcades have been set up
by uh by protesters and supporters of
the movement
uh they don't allow anyone in not even
the police it's called an autonomous
zone
and
it's very tense near the memorial and a
militant style group has closed off
several blocks with barricades
what's the situation at the memorial the
situation at the memorial
is from what i understand is kind of
volatile
people that want to go and support
doesn't feel a sense of inclusion
there is more of a like militant
type atmosphere over there and a sense
of fear
kim griffin supports police reform and
was outside the courthouse protesting
floyd's death
but she does not agree with what's
happening at the memorial
her nephew 28 year old emez wright was
shot and killed there over the weekend
were police able to get in and help him
we're not allowed to get into that area
he was carried out outside the zone
of george foye square not allowed by who
i mean
they're the police the law enforcement
it was made clear law enforcement was
not welcome to penetrate that
zone uh so law enforcement isn't welcome
they're just not that that's something
you could do if you're on the left if
you're a left-wing activist you could
just say
well you're not welcome here we're gonna
set up we're gonna set up camp here
we're allowed to play revolutionary
for several weeks or several months and
and say to law enforcement yeah we don't
want you here and law enforcement will
turn around and say all right
the thing that that the thing that
always frustrates me about this is that
you
you watch these videos and the people
doing this
are so unintimidating and weak looking
and they're allowed to get away with it
those two people that walked up to the
reporter and said
it's gonna be a bad situation for you if
you don't leave
you got a it's a woman and some scrawny
looking
dude walking up it's gonna be a real bat
you better get the hell out of here
what the hell are you gonna do what are
you gonna do do something about it
i would love to see that response but of
course the reporter just turns around
and walks away
and even the police turn around and say
well yes sir i don't want to
i don't want any bad news from you you
look like a tough customer
and they're allowed to do this but
remember remember again what we're told
by the media
that uh that that these people the
left-wing activists
they're the ones who get the real tough
treatment from law enforcement and the
government
as opposed to the riders on january 6th
one of whom shot to death on the spot if
you recall
uh and then all the others are being
hunted down
by the government and and given you know
being charged with with crimes that will
land them in jail for
10 to 20 years meanwhile the left-wing
activists are allowed to
take over whole city blocks
oh but okay minneapolis leaders say that
we're only going to let them do this
until the end of the trial so we'll give
them a few weeks
more to take over this part of the city
what else are we gonna do i mean if we
if we tell them to go away they'll be
mad at us
they'll be upset
all right number three education week
has an article titled
texas school districts face safety
dilemma after governor lifts mask order
and this is about schools in texas
deciding whether to have mask mandates
in their individual schools
because the statewide mandate has been
taken away but the governor said that
you know individual districts and and uh
localities can
come up with their own policies um and
this is
you're seeing this more and more as more
schools open they're dealing with this
question of
should we have the kids wearing masks
all day and a lot of schools are they
have these kids wearing masks
all day while they're in in in school
but let me help you out if you're if
you're
a school district dealing with this
question should we have the kids in
masks all day should we not
um you should not very very easy answer
you absolutely should not
masks for kids especially if they're
going to be wearing
all day in school are not only
unnecessary because we know that kids
are not a major risk
group both for contracting and spreading
the virus
but also so unbelievably unsanitary and
gross
i mean think about anyone who's a parent
of especially younger kids
think about i mean i think about my my
kids now
my son at the age of seven at the end of
the day
just like his shirt will look like he
dug it out of the bottom of a dumpster
and it did not look that way in the
morning when we put it on him we
everything is nice and clean put it on
him and within
hours really within minutes sometimes it
it looks um
gross and he can go through he could go
through four or five shirts in a day and
make them all look like that
because kids are dirty it's part of
being a kid
part of the fun of being a kid they're
not very hygiene focused
you work with them on that but that's
not a concern that they have
and then you're gonna take this piece so
you you think about what a shirt looks
like on a child
after wearing it all day now you can
take a piece of cloth and put it over
their mouth
and have them simply stewing in their
own germs
all day it's disgusting
i have so many times when i've been at
the store been out
um i have heard parents
telling their kids i i've heard
sentences like
stop licking your mask stop
chewing on your mask these are things
you have to now i don't say that to my
kids because i don't really make them
wear a mask in the first place
but if i did that i'd be telling them
the same thing that's what a kid's gonna
do a six-year-old
do you have any idea what they're doing
under that mask
it's like snot and they're licking it
just
gross and you have them wearing it all
day
i mentioned this yesterday on twitter
and someone said well easy solution
uh just give your child an extra mask
give them two or three extra masks then
you can change them out you'll always
have a clean
one see this is the problem the people
pushing for and advocating these
policies don't know the first
damn thing about kids okay
you give them extra masks here's what's
gonna happen
either those extra masks are also going
to look like they've been stewing in a
dumpster
or more likely the kid's going to lose
them
you think you can give your kid an extra
mask and he's still going to have it
two hours later i put shoes on my kids
as we've been over
and they won't even still have those two
hours later and they're on there the
shoes are on their feet
you think you can just give them a few
extra masks
they're going to vary responsibly when
they notice that the first mask is a
little dirty
they'll take that one off neatly put
that away to be cleaned take out the
next one
that's what kids are gonna do sure it's
so disgusting there is no way whatever
whatever minor risk
uh whatever comparatively minor risk
there is for kids with covid and
spreading covet
there is no way that it outweighs
the the hygiene concerns of having these
kids wear masks all day
meanwhile dr fauci on cnn was asked to
explain
why people who've been vaccinated can't
return to traveling in other normal
activities
and he didn't have a good answer as
always but here's what he said
we know from the bind administration
that they say it will make its decisions
based on
science what's the science behind
not saying it's safe for people who have
been vaccinated receive two doses
to travel you know that's a very good
question john and and the cdc
is carefully heading in that direction
uh
you know when we when when dr walensky
made the announcement
a day or two ago about the fact that
when you have a couple of people two or
three or more people in a family setting
both of whom are vaccinated even if it's
someone from another a friend that
doesn't have to be a member of the
family
that was the first in a multi-step
process
that they are going to be rolling out
they're being careful understandably
they want to get science they want to
get data
and then when you don't have the data
and you don't have the actual
evidence then you've got to make a
judgment call and i think that's what
you're going to be seeing
in the next weeks you're going to see
little by little more and more
guidelines getting people to be more and
more flexible
the first installation of this is what
can vaccinated people do in the home
setting
obviously the next one is going to be
what you're asking
what about travel what about going out
what about getting a haircut what about
doing things like that
that's all imminently going to be coming
out what about getting a haircut
i can't is there anyone i guess if you
live in a state or a city where they
still have this stuff shut down there's
not a lot you can do but
is there anyone still waiting around in
their own personal life
to to hear the guidelines like
you're not going to do anything even if
it's available to you you're not going
to do it until you get the guidelines
from fauci and see
the cdc is there anyone still doing that
well yeah i guess a lot a lot of people
are
haven't grown tired of it yet
and so fauci is saying well we gotta we
don't have the data yet so
we'll just air on the side we'll air on
the side of having people continue
to be shut away in their homes not
living their lives let's continue to err
on that side
even if they've been vaccinated
you just don't if you are stop waiting
around for this dude
and for the cdc and and simply go live
your life
uh one other note on covid here one
other coveted related thing number four
this is from cnbc a story related to
something we discussed at the beginning
of the week
but more details are now coming out uh
it says an overwhelming majority of
people who have been hospitalized needed
a ventilator or died from coca-19
have been overweight or obese so the
story that we had a couple days ago
was that uh the the countries that have
obesity epidemics like our own
are also the ones that have been hit hit
the hardest by by covid
no surprise there now this gets more
specific it says among 148
494 adults who received a covenant 19
diagnosis during an emergency department
or inpatient visit at 238 u.s hospitals
from march to december
uh 71 000 were hospitalized of those who
were admitted
27 were overweight and 50 were obese
so you've got almost 78 percent
overweight is defined as having a body
mass index of 25 or more while obesity
is defined as having a bmi
of 30 or more now you hear that
it seems very significant and it is uh
because we know that
this is something that has affected
overweight and obese people
um in a hugely disproportionate way
one word of caution i would mention and
that's why i think we need even
more information i would be curious for
more information on this
um because the categories
overweight and obese are and i don't
mean this as a pun
are very broad and so i i think
i'd like to know more when we talk about
overweight and obese what exactly do you
mean by that
and the reason i say that is that if you
go to cdc website
uh and you go to their section their
obesity section
and you look at their little charts
telling you you know
based on your height and your sex when
are you
what qualifies as overweight or obese
for you
you look at that chart it's madness
i mean for example according to the cdc
i'm i'm six foot six foot one on a good
day
uh some would say six foot but six foot
one on a good day
and for my heights i i'm told that i
think like
certainly at 150 pounds according to cdc
i'm in the normal range at 150 pounds
for a six foot one inch man i would be
skin and bones
i i would look i would be like tom hanks
after
on in castaway after three years on the
island if i was if i was 150 pounds at
my height
and if i remember correctly it's like
you know
140 145 all the way down to there for my
height you'd be 140 pounds will still be
considered normal
up to maybe like 180 175 180.
above that you're overweight
so by the cdc's
standards they expect men to have
no muscle mass whatsoever if you've ever
even been inside a gym
if you've if you've ever taken one rep
on a on a bench press
then you're probably going to be
overweight if not obese by the cdc's
definition
so i'd be curious about that when they
say overweight and obese are we talking
about
six foot one men or 200 pounds which i
think is a healthy weight for for a man
that height
are we talking about 270 pounds is that
what you mean
big difference okay number five finally
from the daily wire it says
unilever the company that makes dove
soap and other beauty and personal care
products
announced this week that it would stop
using the word normal on its packaging
because it's not inclusive enough
reuters reported that the london-based
company will also
stop digital alterations of body shapes
and skin color of models used in its
advertising
the but then it goes on to say that
doesn't appear to be any backlash that
caused the current move by unilever to
remove the word normal from its
packaging
but a poll conducted by the company that
surveyed ten thousand people found
global support for removing the word so
they're just anticipating it this is
what companies are going to do now
they're going to drive the woken sanity
by trying to get out in front of it
but setting the precedent so the woke
mob
hasn't quite yet gotten around to
actually being offended by the word
normal
but unilever is saying they'll get
around to it soon so we're
going to get rid of the word now and
then woke mob looks at that and they say
yeah you know what that is offensive
good point wokeness will
eventually make it impossible to
advertise anything because advertising
is all about advancing
some ideal you know some notion of how
things should be
and that's that's not inclusive
you can't really advertise your message
um or advertise your product
if your message is that everyone is
perfect and fine just the way they are
that's the problem
even with a lot of you know dove a lot
of women's products and
toiletries and cosmetics stuff in that
vein
you know for years now the main they've
been trying to
walk this tightrope where the message is
everyone is beautiful
everyone is wonderful just how they are
you're all you're all
princesses and goddesses uh but by the
way you'd be a lot better if you had our
product
wait a second i thought you just said
i'm perfect how i am
so it's gonna become it's gonna become
impossible eventually for these
companies to advertise
um which maybe isn't such a bad thing
that might be the one good thing that
that comes of
of the woke mob less advertising from
these kinds of companies
all right we're going to move on now to
read the youtube comments and remember
speaking of youtube
if you're watching on youtube to uh hit
smash the like button as the kids say
comment subscribe hit the notification
bell
um and you know i decided i think we're
almost at 200 000 subscribers on youtube
and once we get to half a million we're
a long way off
but once we get there there's gonna be a
special treat i don't know exactly what
it is yet
maybe i will perform slam poetry
that's it i will have a a a
an original slam work of slam poetry
that i will perform
on this show when we get to half a
million that's your incentive
might be more like a d incentive than
anything else okay this is
miley ztv says my daily routine has
become watching this damn show
i'm addicted well a little aggressive a
little negative in the way you put it
but uh but thanks for watching
milton sanchez says matt um
are you rolling around town in a super
dope sports car or are you living the
dad life cruising in a minivan
uh none of the above we we go the suv
route
i'm fine with the minivan my wife still
eventually every parent breaks down
i've i've i got there a couple of years
ago where i said fine let's just do the
damn minivan
whatever it's a lot easier it you know
we've had the experience with minivan a
couple of times when our car's been in
the shop we've had a rent and
rent a car and uh yeah the minivan it's
not a looker it's not gonna win any
style points but it is so much easier
and more convenient than any other kind
of car for for hauling a bunch of kids
around
so eventually every every parent breaks
down i got there my wife is not she's
not ready yet
for that uh to be a minivan mom quite
yet
and so she'll be there soon but as it
happens right now we're not we're not
doing it
levin says on the way we're we're on the
way to jesus being canceled well we're
already
there in fact one of the uh one viral
video that well i
was planning to talk about on the show
this this week maybe we'll still get
around to it but
a viral video been making the rounds on
online i think originates on tiktok of
course is and i believe this guy
calls himself a pastor but he's talking
about how jesus was a racist
so yeah we're we're already there
i mean in a way you know we've been
there for 2000 years
but um but eventually a more concerted
effort will we get to a point i guess
the question is
where because of the bible's quote hate
speech it can't be sold on amazon will
we get to that point
that's the question i would say probably
eventually yeah
daniel stevens says do you shapiro
knowles and clavin share a trauma bond
over all the insults y'all get online
is there any caressing and crying in
each other's arms off screen
asking for a friend don't cancel me yeah
we that that's what we need because
we know taylor lorenz and other female
journalists have been talking about this
a lot this week
how they get mean comments and there's a
lot of trauma and you do you do
you do need a support system and so at
least we have each other for that
it can be very upsetting the mean
comments
um and finally have you noticed that you
can freely fulfill any of your wretched
desires by simply calling yourself
anti-wretched desire if you want to be
racist call yourself anti-racist
you want to practice fascist tactics
boom call yourself
anti-fascist on the flip side you want
to follow the science
you'll be labeled anti-science you have
cracked the code that is
indeed exactly how it works you know i
really believe the world would be a much
better place if people spend
at least as much time reading books as
they do scrolling through social media
probably more a lot more time reading
books even
but let's start small let's try to do a
50 50 split here
if you agree with me and have been
looking for a new title to check out
look no further the new york times
bestselling author and renowned podcast
host
none other than our very own andrew
clavin just released the third and final
installment
of his another kingdom series the
emperor's sword
finds austin lively on the run between
two realities as his enemies close on
all sides
despite wild success in life he begins
to realize that a recurring vision is
actually a nightmare in disguise he's
caught in the coils of a terrible magic
and the only way he can
save his soul is to give up his success
re-enter the 11 lands and find the
emperor anastasius
so he can restore queen linda to her
throne the first two books in the series
didn't disappoint so i will personally
be sitting down to find
how this uh this whole adventure
concludes the emperor's sword is now
available for purchase online go to
amazon.com and search
the emperor's sword also i got to tell
you about
of course the candace owen show i just
mentioned earlier in the show on
election night we announced that candace
owens will be joining the daily wire
and it's finally happening candace's new
show candace will premiere
next friday march 19th um and this is
going to be
an exclusive to daily wire members if
you're not a member go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code candice to get 25
off also as i mentioned you can go to my
youtube channel i've got an interview
with her
uh she's got a lot of content all the
different channels um
as we you know start to bring candace
into the into the fold
again that's dailywire.com subscribe use
code candace to get 25
off now let's get to our daily
cancellation
so today we have a few cancellations to
dole out and it all begins with this
question sent
into slate's advice column now anybody
who sends a question to slate's advice
column deserves to be cancelled on that
basis alone
i cannot imagine ever facing a quandary
in my life where i think to myself man
you know slate might know what to do
here
i have never been in a situation where i
wondered
what slate might say about it and that's
mostly because i know what slate would
say they'd say that the cause of the
problem is racism sexism and transphobia
literally no matter what the problem
actually is the problem could be like a
flat tire or
arthritis or anything and that would be
slate's answer
but this guy who uses the pseudonym
suddenly the breadwinner
thought that slate would be the best
best place to go with his issue and
here's what he wrote
it's a little bit long but let's read
the whole thing bear with me he says i
am a new father to a beautiful 10 month
old girl
my wife's company has a generous
maternity leave policy and she has been
at home with her daughter since the
birth
and is scheduled to go back to work just
after her first birthday in january
she recently told me she doesn't want to
go back to her job and would like to be
a stay-at-home parent instead
i asked her why and she said she enjoys
being a mother too much to leave our
daughter to go back to work
when she doesn't need to it's such a
departure from our plans before the baby
was born she had a good job
that she enjoyed before going on leave
and had always been adamant that she
wanted to continue working even after
becoming a mom
we met when we worked at the same
company many years ago one of the things
i was most attracted to
to about her was her ambition and
tenacity it's really surprising to hear
that her career isn't that important to
her anymore honestly
i don't want her to quit her job she
earns about the same as i do and while
we could make ends meet on my income
alone it would impact our daily ability
or our ability to save and we need to
give up one of our cars
and cut back on extras that make life
more enjoyable
i also just don't want to stay at home
mom wife
i really admired my wife for her work
ethic and i want her to set a good
example for our daughter too
seeing her give up like this is really
disappointing
i gently asked her if she thought her
change in attitude could be related to a
possible
mental health issue or postpartum
depression
but she didn't take that well she says
she only cares about our daughter and
that's where all her energy needs to go
right now and that if i love her i will
let her do this
i do love my wife and i'm not interested
in divorce but i'm seeing a whole side
of her that i just don't like or admire
what should i do
okay well i mean as long as he gently
asked
he gently asked whether his wife wants
to stay home and raise their daughter
due to a mental illness
hey honey uh listen i i know you said
you love being a mother
you want to be home with our child
full-time i'm just wondering i'm just
wondering
are you having a psychotic break is that
what this is
i'm only asking what i'm just asking
i can't believe that didn't go over well
now
i admit that i might be judging this man
extra harshly because i am also the
breadwinner
in my family and we have four little
mouths to feed instead of one
and i personally really like supporting
my family i feel honored to do it
fulfilled by it
um and i love that my kids have their
mom home with them
the idea of being disappointed about
being the breadwinner as a man
is completely foreign to me the idea of
respecting
my and admiring your wife less because
she loves being a mom
too much is also utterly foreign to me
but we'll respond more to these ideas
um in a second first let's loop in
our dear friend jill felopivic she's a
feminist writer who
always has exactly the sort of take you
expect on these kinds of issues
in a series of tweets she responded
empathizing with the man and empathizing
with men is usually not one of her
strong suits
and she said in part quote i realize
this is like the third rail of the mommy
wars but yeah lots of super ambitious
people
marry other super ambitious people
because they're attracted to ambition
i would have a really really hard time
being married to a spouse who chose not
to work
and now i'm really going to get myself
yelled at but i also think the issue of
example setting for a kid is totally
fair what example are you setting when
dad works for pay and mom does the care
work at home
lots of reasons not to want to see it to
set that kind of example for a child
at home work is incredibly isolating it
also occupies a pretty unique space
where it's centered on one of the most
fundamental familial relationships
parent slash child
no other job is like that which is where
the claim that staying at home is a job
doesn't quite tell the whole story okay
now
there's a lot to be said on this topic
we don't have time to say most of it
instead i just want to focus on two
things
maybe not even the two most important
things but these two things
first the idea that you have to choose
between being ambitious or raising your
children full-time is asinine
ambition in the positive sense of the
word is simply
a strong desire to achieve some kind of
worthwhile goal
coupled with the determination to see it
through that's what we mean when we
speak positively about an ambitious
person
raising children and tending to your
family in your home requires a lot of
ambition
or to put it another way there's a big
difference between children who are
raised ambitiously
and children who are not so to have
ambition as a parent is to be active to
be present
not complacent here's here's a very
simple example of
ambitious parenting and this again is by
far not the most profound
example but as i said a simple everyday
example
an ambitious parent turns the tv off
says to the kids hey let's go outside
and play a game let's have a scavenger
hunt let's do some
activity that i have planned some
edifying and educational and fun
activity
that i have planned that we're gonna go
do rather than just having you sit here
and watch tv all day
now this is not necessarily the parents
idea of a good time but it's good for
the kids in the long run and you're
putting the work and effort
in in pursuit of that long-term benefit
rather than simply letting them watch tv
and play video games all day
at the end of the day as a parent you
know
if you parented ambitiously or not
and you may be more worn out after the
day of ambitious parenting
but there's also a deep fulfillment that
you feel from it and i would submit that
in many cases
parenting provides more chances to have
that kind of feeling that sort of
satisfied tired feeling of knowing you
put a hard day's work in and you were
ambitious and
you know you and proactive parenting
provides more opportunities to feel that
way
than a nine to five job does in many
nine to five jobs the structure is
already laid out your function is
limited
ambition doesn't even come into play
most of the time
there isn't much room to set your own
path as a parent
there is no structure but what you put
in place
there is no plan but what you devise
and if you don't put a structure in
place if you have no plan if you don't
do anything
if you just let the days flow by
counting on the glowing screens to keep
your kids distracted
sure you're going to feel totally empty
alone bored and miserable
but that's where ambition comes into
play
second point no being a stay-at-home mom
is not a job it's not
a job is something you get specifically
paid to do
many jobs require you to punch in and
punch out you might even get a name tag
parenting involves none of that it's not
a job but it is work
okay that's the distinction here a job
is just a type of work
being a stay-at-home mom is not a job
but it is a type of work running a
self-sustaining farm
is also not a job but it's definitely
work
the real question is whether a job is a
more noble
more worthwhile more important kind of
work than parenting and the answer to
that is obviously no
not all jobs are created equal some jobs
are more important than others
just as not all parents are created
equal some parents are better than
others
but speaking in broad strokes here
working for working for a wage at the
behest of a large company under the
supervision of bosses and managers
is not some kind of noble romantic thing
it's also not liberating
the idea that a woman is liberated from
the servile bonds of motherhood by
becoming a wage slave for a corporation
is frankly ridiculous nothing wrong with
working a job i do it
somebody in the family's got to do it
let's not delude ourselves about the
nature of what we're doing at our jobs
here's the other tough reality you are
replaceable
at your job totally replaceable we all
are
your value to your employer is entirely
based on how well you perform
if they can find someone who performs
better than you
you go from limited value to no value
and either way once you exit one way or
another whether you leave on your own or
are fired
the hole you leave behind will be filled
and you'll be quickly forgotten
that's what it means to work at a job it
means that your worth is quantified in
dollars and cents it means that whatever
you do
you're only doing it because and so long
as you're given money in return
and there's nothing fundamentally wrong
with any of this as i said someone's got
to do it
but it's hard to see this as somehow
more admirable than full-time parenting
jobs are mercenary jobs are temporal
jobs are revolving doors parenting is
none of that
or at least it shouldn't be which is why
even though i have a job i find
my real worth and value at home with my
family because that's what really
matters
and if you even if you don't have a
family um well you still
better find your worth and value
somewhere else you better find
some deeper more meaningful thing to
find your worth and value in
than your job
that's the case for everybody and so
parents who do this full-time
incredibly worthwhile and valuable thing
people who can't see that
like our friend jill and the guy who
wrote that letter
are of course canceled and we'll leave
it there for today thanks for watching
thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledovsky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show president
biden celebrates passage of the largest
pork bill in american history the white
house continues to deny a crisis on the
border while incentivizing a crisis on
the border
and the new york times finally finds an
employee they will defend that's today
on the ben shapiro show give it a listen